as per the game's website description
the show is a first-person story driven
game with an atmospheric environment
and also narrations you will encounter
mysterious creatures and unravel the
secrets behind them
there will be a strong element of horror
and you will have to struggle to survive
an unknown world that will make you
question your own sanity
the show is a game that focuses on the
mystery of the unknown on a forbidden
island with horror elements
the whole story is based on the
mythology that goes deep through
lovecraft's creations and beyond
this game was first initiated in october
2019 and the demo
was just released this july 2020.
in it the player will experience the
world through an immersive atmospheric
gameplay
all along the game the player will
encounter the most nightmarish of
lovecraftian entities
and in order to save the character's
daughter's life
while being haunted and hunted by these
ghoulish and indescribable entities
then you'll have to try to survive and
uncover the secrets behind the mystery
of the character's own sanity itself set
in what is either a small island or a
show line with a creepy lighthouse
the character must roam about and
explore small landscapes
filled with dead sailors sharks and
other marine creatures washed up to the
shore
then at a certain area portals and
shortcuts
to other sites will be available to the
player at the same time while roaming
and exploring the place
the player will encounter numerous
entities some that are humanoid in
appearance
while others that possess tentacles some
small while others that are gigantic in
scale
the inspirations for these monsters are
taken from numerous of lovecraft's works
and the authors that follow in its
footsteps and expand the ketulah mythos
some of them are taken from the works
like the shadow from over inn's mouth
while others from works like a shadow
out of time and of course the call of
cthulhu and even from the mountains of
madness
these horrific entities are brought to
life by excellent cgi and artist
renditions
now let's take a look at seven of these
the living monolith this is straight out
of the mind of lovecraft himself
a symbolic representation of all that is
unnatural and that which is a prime
example of cosmic horror
the name of this tall rock-like monster
is unknown so let's just call it the
living monolith
the player encounters it while searching
for his daughter and after hearing an
eerie voice
that tells him that they can help each
other out then after traveling through a
portal
the path leads him towards several
rotating discs that once a line
wakes up the living monolith this
monster is at least
indifferent towards the character and it
was a hundred feet tall
and looks like a gigantic runic totem
that walked on four legs with three
fingers each
the deep ones the creatures that look
like humans and are the same size but
with skin that's very
smooth and tough and also strong and
well maintained physique
well i guess catholic had a gold gym
back in earlier
well they were described in a small
paper that they had no eyelids and the
eyes resembled that of a shark
and when spoken to they only hissed and
growled like animals
it could only mean one thing in the
cthulhu mythos of course these are the
deep ones i mean
i could be wrong but let's just say that
i'm 90
correct these fish like people are
hostile and are seen in another picture
photobombing a group of people in the
game the player gets to
ask two of these fishy looking people to
death
the dark young although this creature
isn't encountered in the game demo
it is seen in the game's website and
also in one of the papers that the
character discovers inside the
lighthouse
alongside the description of the deep
ones it was said that there is no
symmetry whatsoever in the creature's
design
and that it had many mouths all over its
body with no defined shape or size
this creature however could speak with a
voice that sudden
shivers down the spine i would say that
this is one of the dark young of shop
nigrat
the ones with innumerable tentacles 20
to 30 feet tall
and standing on hoofed legs and they
also possess
mouths all over the body so yeah glad
that one is figure out as well
then we have nail lathotep well this one
i tried to put it off for another time
but the strange
goal to include this one in the video
keeps coming out of nowhere so
anyway even though seen only as a statue
it might
well be another entity that will be
encountered in the future when the full
game is released
i could only guess that it was one of
the outer gods that roamed the earth and
of course it most likely
looked like to be a representation of
nia lathotep with a humanoid upper body
but with strange tentacle heads and
lower body tentacles this other god or
rather a messenger
of them was the aspect of madness and
insanity
which would fit in perfectly with one of
the themes of this game for the
character's sanity in question
the ghost lazy name i know
this entity is later discovered to be
the one that calls and beckons the
character to follow parts and do the
things that lead to the release of
cthulhu later on
there seems to be two forces playing
against and for the character survival
one which wants the release of cthulhu
and maybe at the end discovering the
lost daughter i highly doubt that
though and the other force that wants
katsulu to be tied down for good
well the ghost was one which can summon
giant tentacles out of the ground with
smaller
bright and energy filled offshoots like
twisty and slimy lightsabers
anyway he leads the players to the
location where cthulhu is in prison
and also the ghost is around seven feet
tall
shakthana gotha this creature is an
original name and design of the game
and appears when the player is
transported into a new dimension
that is most likely the final part of
the demo game
and given that it is a demo game the
real one would include many more
scenarios and scenes before this one is
unlocked
it appears to be the soul guardian of
the lair where cthulhu is imprisoned or
at least is slumbering
this creature is called shakta nagotha
appears to be walking and running on
five or six very slimy and long legs
like an insect
but with an upper body that has numerous
attacking tentacles that spurred out
from its
mouth lined with big dagger-like teeth
the size of this character is well over
15 feet tall and
equally long then we have
cthulhu and then we get to the big c
himself the great old one
the sleeper of relier or rather he's
sleeping somewhere else in this game
who would be a drag of the lair he was
slumbering in is the mythical city of
relia
so in the game the player submits an
item called the eye of the watcher and
with that he awakens
the avatar of cthulhu which is no more
than 30 feet tall i was really
kind of disappointed the first time but
then however in the closing scenes of
the game
a giant 200 to 300 foot tall cthulhu
resurfaces from the sea
and as we know he has a huge head with
glowing eyes and tentacles from his
mouth
he also has a humanoid body with two
gigantic wings
and that's that i guess this game is
full of tentacles so as for the future
of the game
it is kind of vague seems like there's a
lot of work being put into it and
since the demo is out the final release
would likely follow soon
there's no official launch date yet but
the show is expected to launch on steam
sometime within 2020 probably in the
winter months
might be a hit if it's a release on
halloween anyway we hope to see
more of these monsters and entities in
the game including the outer gods and
more great old ones later this year
so stay home stay safe and subscribe for
more monster videos i'd rather not i
think that's for good reason you
see him once i'd rather not do
things i'm not supposed to oh wait i'm
shooting yeah
hello mr ctulu nice to meet you
yeah you can have anything yeah yeah
take it take it take a ticket i'm a
[ __ ]
i'm your [ __ ] don't hurt me i'm your
[ __ ]